[MUSIC PLAYING]
PETER BARRON: So great
to have Steve here.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Thank you.
PETER BARRON: I
don't know if you've
had a chance to look
at the book yet,
but it's a splendid
book, which we're
going to talk about for
the next 45 minutes or so.
I was trying to sort of work
out what kind of a book it is.
It's not quite a
coffee table book.
I think it's more sort of
downstairs toilet book.
If you're not from
Britain, you might not
understand the concept of
the downstairs toilet book.
But it's got some great
examples and some great pictures
of protests and mischievous
protests down the years.
So that's the cover.
Steve, tell us
what's going on there
and really what the idea
behind the book was.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
Yes, so the cover,
which I was so happy because
it goes exactly with the title
that we'd already chosen
of "Street Spirit."
And that happens to be
from Germany, from Rostock
in Germany, a meeting of the
G8 governments coming together,
and people were protesting.
And often the protesting is kind
of it's just it is what it is.
But this element of mischief
and people dressing up as clowns
and here's something
really serious going on.
The people were looking very--
and the clowns are just
making a little bit
of a mischievous
element to that.
And if you like, just
parodying as they go along.
Now as it happens, that is
within functioning democracy
and there was nothing
really that bad
that was going on at that time.
But exactly that kind of
mischief and creative mischief
is what we see in authoritarian
and repressive places
around the world, and with
incredible impact quite often.
PETER BARRON: Yeah,
I mean, just reading
the book it kind of struck me
that what you're really talking
about is postmodern protesting.
In some cases, literally sort
of postmodern protesting.
It's sort of looking into
the dynamics of a protest,
how authorities
respond to the protest,
and then how people
respond to the response.
And it's very
fascinating, I think.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: I
guess that's right.
I mean, one of the things
that is so interesting
is that clearly
protests, if there's
lots of people, that's going
to be a more effective protest
than if fewer people.
But one of the things
that interested me
so much over the years is that
little bit of the quirkiness
draws more people in
because they just feel
more engaged what's happening.
And also, again and again
you notice that regimes
have zero sense of humor.
And that's always the case.
And so when you're
mocking them, they're
always like on the
back foot, if you like.
And that's been really
interesting to see also.
PETER BARRON: Yeah.
And we've got a few
pictures from the book.
And Christina, our
human clicker back here,
is going to click through.
But you obviously kicked
off with "The Independent"
during the extraordinary period
of the fall of the Berlin Wall
and were a great
chronicler of that.
And this is kind of a very early
example of what we are talking
about, which is from Poland.
Talk us through
what happened here.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: So Poland
is a country very dear
to my own heart.
And it's kind of what
I saw there and lived
through kind of shaped
my understanding
of the world in many ways.
I happened to be
living there in 1980.
I'd been studying theater and
was teaching English there
when the this incredible
organization Solidarity began.
Mass strikes in the north and
across the country in Gdansk
and the ports and
across the country,
which demanded new freedoms.
And it was kind of for an
independent trade union.
That's how it was billed.
That's how they
billed themselves.
But actually, it kind of was
like an informal opposition.
And it seemed impossible,
utterly unthinkable
that that could be achievable
in the context of the Cold War
at that time, divided Europe.
This was Moscow
dominated Soviet Bloc.
Nothing could happen.
And all the Western
commentators said,
this isn't going anywhere.
You can't do this.
The Russians won't allow it.
And the courage and the
imagination of the Poles
actually they achieved
Solidarity's legalization.
And I was living through that
time, watched the live TV
broadcast when it
happened, it was like, wow.
Like how did that happen?
The following year,
Solidarity was banned.
Tanks went to the streets, and
everyone said yeah, exactly.
We told you that wasn't
going to go anywhere anyway.
But actually, the real
story is how Poles said, no.
Actually, it will.
So the picture that
we're seeing there
is one of my favorite ones.
Martial law was introduced.
The tanks went on the streets.
And as in so many places,
people, of course,
were painting political
graffiti onto the wall
and were saying long live
Solidarity, that kind of stuff.
And again, as happens so often,
the police or the authorities
come along and--
PETER BARRON: They
painted over it.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Wipe it out.
PETER BARRON: Yeah.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: So you had all
these blank spaces all around.
And this wonderful group
called the Orange Alternative,
a kind of surrealist protest
group if you like really,
action group, well
they came along
and they painted
gnomes or dwarves.
It's the same word in Polish for
like "Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs."
It's that concept, people
wearing little red hats.
And they would paint these
things onto the walls.
And the gnomes became
like, we want the gnomes.
Freedom for the gnomes.
The authorities had no idea what
to do or how to confront this.
PETER BARRON:
"Freedom for gnomes"
became the first slogan.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: "Freedom
for gnomes" became first.
Instead of saying
freedom for Solidarity,
"no freedom without
Solidarity" was the chant,
they started saying "no
freedom without gnomes."
The authorities arrest people.
There was one great thing
where the police were
heard to be messaging each other
saying, arrest all the gnomes,
arrest all the gnomes,
because everyone had turned up
with their red hats.
And that, and you can say
OK, it's a little story,
but the thing was lots and lots
of little stories like that
led to the fact that Poland
was the very first place that
broke open the Soviet
Bloc, if you like.
They got a non-communist
government already
in August 1989, which was before
the Berlin Wall had come down.
And I always say it
was the gnomes who
helped make that happen.
PETER BARRON: And did
they paint out the gnomes
or did they let the gnomes--
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
Yeah, yeah, of course.
They then repainted
out the gnomes.
But instead of having "we demand
Solidarity" painted back on,
the gnome that was
painted out would then
be repainted with a gnome.
You know, the authorities knew,
they couldn't quite know why,
but they knew that these gnomes
were not good in some way.
PETER BARRON: This comes across
again and again in the book.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: It was
Red Riding Hood also
at one point became something.
Like oh, Red Riding Hood.
They found later
the secret police
files which said we're very
worried about this Red Riding
group.
PETER BARRON: So it's very hard.
It comes across again, the
authorities not quite knowing
what to do.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
And each time you
have the humor, the
authorities go like oh, we
know this is mocking us, but
we don't know quite what to do.
It's great.
PETER BARRON: And actually,
some extraordinary examples
of completely flipping it on
its head, so governments got--
this was Belarus, wasn't it?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yeah.
PETER BARRON: Where the
government got annoyed
about people applauding,
because people
started applauding in protest.
So actually doing something like
saying I love the authority.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: That's right.
PETER BARRON: The authorities
go, we don't want their love,
because that's
embarrassing to us.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: They
knew it can't be true,
like when you were clapping.
So what happened, yes, you
have Alexander Lukashenko.
Belarus is sometimes described
as the last dictatorship
in Europe.
I mean, a very
authoritarian regime there,
which really doesn't permit
protest in any sense.
Very, very difficult society
to give voice, if you like.
And so as you say,
people started
doing it ironically like OK,
well we love our president.
And people would
stand up every-- it
happened on a weekly basis.
And they would start clapping.
And it's like yeah, but
you're not really clapping,
so we're going to
arrest you for clapping.
That got to the ludicrousness
that one guy who
was actually one armed also got,
quote, "arrested for clapping."
And they forbade people
to do any of these things.
And the people, of
course, normally
repressive leaders
adore to be applauded.
You know, so Soviet papers
when I was living there
as a student in
the old, old days,
there would be a lot of
things, bracketed things
saying you know,
"stormy applause," "very
stormy applause,"
"stormy applause which
becomes an ovation."
They adore this stuff, just
like in North Korea today,
if you like.
But the fact that
people were doing it
and they knew it was
ironic, it was like, well,
if they want to do
it, then we definitely
don't want them to do it.
That was the kind of
logic that came through.
PETER BARRON: And the
next picture, and this
is again an early
example of thumbing
the nose at the authority.
But this is Leipzig, I
think early on in Germany.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: That's right.
Yeah, I mean, yeah,
this was less--
there was less
mischief, if you like.
But here there was just pure
courage and incredible--
we're talking about moments
that have formed my life.
This evening, the evening
when this picture was taken,
the 9th of October
1989, one of the most
moving and extraordinary
evenings of my life.
And the reason it
was so extraordinary
was because absolutely
nothing happened.
And I'll describe
what that means.
This was a few months
after Poland had already
broken through as described.
They had an non-communist
prime minister.
Again, kind of as unthinkable as
having one in North Korea today
would be.
I mean, it just
changed everything.
And it all started
before Mikhail Gorbachev
arrived, and then after.
And in the meantime, in East
Germany still very repressed
and people were
protesting, protesting.
And in the city of
Leipzig there had been
protests every single Monday.
And people were being beaten.
They were being arrested.
And the authorities
were getting very edgy.
They were getting
edgy enough they
said, OK, if you come
out this coming Monday
night we will shoot you.
It was put in the form
of a reader's letter,
but everyone understood it.
Saying you know,
we've had enough
of these
counter-revolutionary actions,
in other words,
peaceful protests.
We will take action
quote, unquote,
"if need be with
weapons in our hands."
Wow.
The city was closed off to
journalists and any visitors.
I was very lucky to get
through and even luckier
that I didn't get kicked
out when I arrived there.
So I was there on
that Monday evening.
Met with one guy who was
going to one of the protest
leaders who was
telling his daughter,
you must on no account
go on this protest.
He was frightened that
she was going to die.
It was OK for him to die,
but not for his daughter.
So that was an
interesting confrontation.
The hospital wards were cleared.
Everyone knew there
would be shooting.
And I kind of checked out
a place where I thought,
I'm going to be safe
here, you know, et cetera.
But basically, that was
what people thought.
And the authorities, of course,
thought, why wouldn't they,
we have threatened
you so clearly you
will all stay at home.
And actually as we see in this
image, many, many, many, many,
many more people came out
that night than ever before.
And like more or
less minutes before,
as the protests got underway,
it started in a church
and then outside, they went like
OK, there's kind of too many.
We won't shoot tonight.
PETER BARRON: And there
was literally no--
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: And they
didn't even beat people.
PETER BARRON: There was
literally no violence at all.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
There was no violence.
So there was this
surreal moment.
You're all kind
of living in fear.
You're waiting for the bullets.
And I'd seen the trucks
full of armed men
before the protest began,
like 15 trucks or something.
You absolutely knew it
was going to happen.
Hospital wards cleared.
And then you walk
out waiting for that,
and like that doesn't happen.
And they don't do anything.
There's no beating.
There's no arresting,
all of the things
that had happened
every week and which
I'd seen in Berlin just a
couple of days before as well.
And at that point, as one
woman said to me afterwards,
I felt as though I could fly.
And there was a real--
there was, I have to
say, an absolute chemical
adrenalin buzz.
It flips from the fear to the
wow, look what's happened.
And a month to the
very day after that
the Berlin Wall came down.
And people always tell
the story of oh, it
happened because of
this and that and that
and it was so
surprising, they said.
And it happened because
of a piece of paper that
went missing or other things.
Really, if you look at the
courage of the Leipzigers,
that is kind of what brought it.
It's called-- in Leipzig, it's
called the Miracle of Leipzig.
And it kind of was.
And it's about courage.
PETER BARRON: And
there's a big theme
in the book about the
importance of nonviolence.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yeah.
PETER BARRON: And a
lot of these protests
have said we can do
all kinds of things.
We do all kinds of mischief.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: That's right.
PETER BARRON: We should
never resort to to violence.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
That's right, yeah.
I mean, if you go
for violence, you're
playing to the regime's
strongest suit.
They've got all the tanks.
They've got all the guns.
As we've also seen, of
course, in recent years,
they've got all the planes
that can bomb people.
You know, all of that stuff
they have got when using that.
The one that always
unsettles them but is
incredibly difficult to do--
you know, in difficult
circumstances,
nonviolent protest is
not the easy option.
It's actually the very,
very difficult option.
And I think those
who keep that courage
and keep that nonviolence
achieve astonishing things.
In neighboring
Czechoslovakia, in part of now
Czech Republic and Slovakia,
two countries, Vaclav Havel,
the dissident, playwright, then
later became the president,
he wrote this
magnificent essay called
"The Power of the Powerless."
And he kind of mused
in his writing saying,
well, what would happen if
everybody at the same time
said no.
And he was mocked.
He said afterwards they treated
me like a Czech Don Quixote.
You know like, oh
please, Vaclav, grow up.
And actually, just 11 years
after that in his own country
it happened.
So that power of the powerless
is something which from way
back but continuing to this
day I find so interesting.
PETER BARRON: Yeah.
And actually it tees up
the next picture which
is from Hong Kong, I think.
There we go.
And this is sort of these of--
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yes.
PETER BARRON: --appearing
to be one thing but being
quite another.
In this case it's Hong Kong.
Sort of people going
shopping in there
in the rain with
their umbrellas,
but clearly making a protest.
And there are some
truly fantastic examples
of this in the book.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yeah.
PETER BARRON: Unfortunately,
the Hong Kong one
didn't end so
brilliantly did it?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: That's right.
I mean so it didn't, but
it's not an ended story.
I think that's the
important thing to remember.
So yes, the story that I
particularly focus on, I mean,
these images and I'm sure
others will in a minute
will recognize these
incredibly emblematic protests
that happened in Hong
Kong a few years ago.
And at one point when
people kind of said, well,
we're not actually protesting,
we're just going shopping.
And it was difficult.
And something similar happened
in Beijing and Shanghai,
actually.
People would just
kind of go for a walk.
And the authority
is never quite sure
if someone's going for
a walk, can I arrest you
for going for a walk?
Are you a protester or are
you actually just going
for a coffee or something?
So all of those things are that.
PETER BARRON: I was
familiar with this one,
but I wasn't familiar
with the one in Thailand
around sandwich eating.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yes.
PETER BARRON: So sandwich
eating and book reading,
and kind of particular
kinds of books.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: That's right.
Again, it's that turning of
the tables, which I love so.
We had basically military
coup in Thailand.
And you weren't allowed
to express opinions
on a whole range of things.
Still less were you allowed
to gather to protest.
And what people did
was kind of make
taking such an innocent activity
like for example, book reading
or indeed having a picnic,
because that became
a soft way of having
a gathering was we
are quote, "having a picnic,"
which has happened elsewhere as
well.
So what people did was
deliberately and very
demonstratively they would
sit there with a sandwich
and with a book.
And there would be
lots of people sitting
with a sandwich and a book.
So what kind of protest is that?
You're not chanting slogans,
you're not doing anything.
But the people in
authority knew, again,
that they were being
kind of mocked.
And so it was a way
of doing something
which was still courageous.
You could still absolutely
get arrested for doing that.
But in a way that was
a little bit sideways,
a little wrong for
the authorities.
PETER BARRON: And the book
happened to be "1984,"
didn't it?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: That's
right, some of the people.
People chose different
books, but very popular one
for very obvious reasons
was George Orwell's "1984,"
exactly.
PETER BARRON: Great.
So next picture.
So this is kind of coming
up to the more modern era.
This is obviously
the famous picture
from Black Lives Matter.
But what struck me that was
interesting about Black Lives
Matter was that although it
clearly became a campaign
and picked up from
organized campaigns,
it was a kind of
accidental campaign.
I mean, even the phrase
"Black Lives Matter"
was kind of stumbled upon.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yeah, people
often talk about organizing.
And organizing is
really important,
but actually organic growth
with the kind of serendipities
of little chance events often
lead to different things.
The image itself I love is
obviously very well well-known.
It's been described
as a Botticelli
image, which I rather love.
It is that kind of
that graciousness.
And it goes to what
you were describing,
the nonviolence
and the violence.
It's like, I am more
powerful, says that woman,
by not responding with the force
that you're coming out with.
I trump, I trump your
force with my non-force.
And it's a very,
very powerful image.
And she herself spoke
powerfully about what
it meant to her afterwards.
But as you say, it
didn't come from nowhere.
It started-- it had the killing
of Trayvon Martin famously
a couple of years earlier.
And the person who had killed
him was then acquitted.
And then it was appealed again.
And it started as a kind
of cry from the heart
of saying our lives matter.
And the hashtag quickly changed
and it was just a Facebook post
changed to Black Lives Matter.
But it didn't immediately
get much pickup.
It was just kind of shared
between friends, shared
between friends
who were like yeah,
this does actually--
you know, we all matter
and black lives
matter within that.
And then it was then
another killing,
the killing of Michael
Brown the following year.
At a certain point it just
caught and people felt yes,
this matters so much.
And so what had started
with three friends
basically in the Bay
Area and then became
this huge national
thing and indeed,
became global as
well of confronting
so much changes needed.
Now as we all know, the
problems are still massive.
But even within that, it's
been really interesting to see.
There have already
been Black Lives Matter
victories, if you
like, of you know,
chiefs of police being
replaced, elected out
where they weren't expected
to where it was like we do
need to do something about that.
Clearly it's a massive problem.
And again, I do feel
this image is wonderfully
emblematic of that, Mike.
All I'm doing is
asking for rights.
I will stand here until
those basic rights are there
and basic justice, if you like.
It's about justice.
About people, put
at it crudest level,
not being killed for
the color of their skin.
And that's how bad it is in
what should be a functioning
democracy today.
PETER BARRON: And
very similar image
to some of the famous
images of people
putting flowers in the
rifles of the guards.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
Yeah, that's right.
It goes back, it goes back.
PETER BARRON: And
the one that I really
liked, which I hadn't
seen before, was the I
think the Ukraine women
standing in a similar position
with a mirror holding the
mirror up to the soldiers.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yes.
PETER BARRON: I think
you say in the book
that as a result
of soldiers looking
in the mirror at
themselves, they
kind of changed their position
and moved to to the other side.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
I love that one.
Mirrors have been used quite
often to kind of look yourself
in the face.
What are you doing?
And that was lovely.
You had both young women
and much older, grandmothers
as well standing there.
And you could see the riot
police were standing, really
muscly guys, very much like
the American image in a sense.
You are ready to do anything.
And they had killed people
and they would kill people
again during those protests in
the Ukraine a couple of years
ago, a few years ago.
And the discomfort
of the people,
I don't want to look in
that mirror because you're
my sister, my girlfriend, my
mother, my grandmother like,
don't look at me.
And that was really interesting
that when the president then
finally gave way at the
end of those protests,
the final trigger
a couple of weeks
after these particular
protests, the final trigger
was the fact that the police
had kind of moved away from him.
And then at that point
it was game over.
So again, you can
see the smallest
of connections between this
very peaceful but extremely
courageous image.
Of course those women were
taking considerable risks.
And a large number of people
had already been killed and more
would be, so it wasn't like oh,
let's go and carry a mirror.
That was a really dangerous
and brave thing to do.
PETER BARRON: Now that was
a sort of organic protest.
But a lot images, a lot of
them are actually PR stunts.
There's not a great deal
of difference between a PR
campaign or stunt and a bit of
street spirit mischief making.
So I mean, your organization,
Amnesty International,
obviously had a hand in many
of these down the years.
And there some good
examples in the book.
The one I liked in
particular was Darth Vader
going to buy weapons.
It was Darth Vader and
the Joker turned up
at a weapons manufacture
and said well, why can't I
have that?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: That's right.
PETER BARRON: You sell them to
other bad people, why not me?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: So they
turn up in the limousine
with the darkened glass.
And so the chauffeur gets out
and am I in the right place
to buy weapons?
Yeah, you're in the right place.
Good, good.
Because the (NON-ENGLISH)
the boss needs to come in.
Then the boss gets out and
turns out to be Darth Vader.
And then they denied it.
And as you say, it's like
well, I don't understand.
You sell weapons
to all the bad guys
and I'm the ultimate bad guy.
So like why wouldn't
I get the weapons?
Now that, of course, is
not taking risks at all,
although the police did
come after the people who
were filming that for
Amnesty International.
The arms manufacturers
called the police
about this unwarranted
infringement.
And so the police came after
them, and that's in the video
also.
But in a way, that was just
a way of engaging people
to think really?
So is my country and the arms
manufacturers of my country,
they're selling
weapons over there?
We need to have international
law stopping that.
And it all contributed to an
international arms trade treaty
that now exists and makes
it illegal basically
to sell weapons to
people who are going
to do bad things with them.
It still goes on, of course.
So I mean, we haven't
got the end of the story,
to put it mildly, as we're
seeing in Yemen and Syria
and so many other places.
But the fact of those laws
being put in place, so you know,
Darth Vader helped
create a safer world.
PETER BARRON: And can
you say a little bit
about how Amnesty thinks
about that kind of campaign?
Where does a campaign
like that come from?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Well, I
guess Amnesty International
is a movement of millions of
people around the world whose
members and supporters who have
that sense that human rights do
matter, and matter
for all of us.
That's kind of what
keeps us safe, actually,
in the biggest sense.
Either your own human
rights, but especially
thinking about others as well.
And we're always, I guess,
looking at the heart
of what we do is document.
We document violations.
We produce these documents full
of facts about the bad things
happening and what needs to
change and how it should change
and why it's in violation
of these laws and that laws.
But what you want
to do, of course,
is to engage people
at the same time.
And so videos like
the one you described
with Darth Vader or many of the
other things that we're doing,
we're constantly
seeking like how can you
easily make people understand.
And not just understand, because
that sounds too patronizing,
because they may understand it.
But like emotionally want to
become engaged in something.
Because if we just
kind of pile on
more and more and
more and more facts
yes, people know it's important,
but at a certain point
they feel I've got a
life to get on with
and it's all just
too depressing.
And of course, some of
what we're describing
is very, very dark.
But what inspires
me, and a way it's
part the stories that
we've been talking about,
is I've seen in my own
lifetime, let alone
working with Amnesty
International as well,
things that seemed
utterly insoluble,
this will never change.
And then wow, it does.
And either it changes
like really quickly.
Or with the Arms
Trade Treaty, that
was 20 years of campaigning
of people saying it
will never, never happen.
You're so naive, they said
to the guy who launched
that campaign originally.
It will never happen.
And then, you know, it did.
PETER BARRON: Amazing.
So the next picture
and this is--
oh no, this is my
favorite story.
This is absolutely fantastic.
I hadn't seen this before.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: And anybody
looking at this image
will say, what's this about?
PETER BARRON: Anyone
familiar with this story?
This is an absolute cracker.
OK, over to you, Steve.
Tell us the story
from the beginning.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: OK, so
although you wouldn't get it
from the headline-- well if you
look at the small print someone
might guess.
So in Burma, in Myanmar, which
as all know military rule
for many, many years,
I was privileged enough
I met Aung San Suu Kyi, the
kind of the opposition leader
who was mostly under house
arrest for many years, partly
in jail under house arrest.
I met her when I was working as
a reporter for the Independent.
And then promptly, of course,
got kicked out of the country
and I was fined.
Got blacklisted for years.
So there she was.
It was a place where dark
things were happening.
And there was this kind
of icon of resistance.
Myanmar, as we
all know, actually
in a very dark place in
a different way today,
but that's kind of
a separate story.
PETER BARRON: I'm going
to ask you about that.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: But
that's a separate story.
That's fine.
But then genuinely enormous
courage shown by her
and many of the
Burmese around her.
She was finally, as a result of
many of the protests by Burmese
of many different
kinds over the years
and it then finally led to the
release of Aung San Suu Kyi.
And on the day that
she was allowed out,
it still, of course,
wasn't democracy.
So the authorities said
to newspaper editors,
on no account must you put this
news-- which was front page
news all around the
world-- on no account
must you put it on
the front pages.
You must kind of bury it.
It's just yeah well, this
woman happens to be out.
PETER BARRON: Page 17.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
Who cares about her.
Bottom of page 17
kind of thing, yeah.
So what we're looking at
here, this sports paper
called First 11 had quite
a bright idea of how
they would confront that.
And so the censors have to
pass every single thing that
goes through.
So they produced
their front page,
which as everyone can see
by looking at it deals
with the English football
games and everything
that's been happening with
Sunderland against Chelsea
and Manchester United
against the Villa and Arsenal
and so on and so
on. it's all there.
That gets sent off by
an old fashioned fax
as a black and white
copy to the censor.
And the censor looks at it and
goes OK, it's a sports page.
PETER BARRON: Sunderland
defeats Chelsea.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: What
do I care about that?
But when it actually came out
on the kiosks the following day,
which obviously was
in the color version--
PETER BARRON: The color version.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
There was the version
which did not make the
censors happy at all,
but did make readers think wow.
So there we can see "Su,"
meaning Aung San Suu Kyi,
is now free.
And we must therefore "unite
and advance to grab the hope."
The paper instantly sold out.
The authorities, of
course, were furious.
They banned the paper.
As far as I remember, they
locked up the editor briefly
and the paper was banned.
But the paper didn't mind.
They knew that act of
mischief and defiance
was bound to end up with
them being punished.
But it was their way
of one in the eye.
And that meant,
basically if you like,
the resistance was continuing.
And that became a
collector's item,
getting a hold of that copy.
And then many, many positive
changes came in the years
after that.
Now bad things are
happening, but those positive
changes I think we
shouldn't forget.
PETER BARRON: Yeah.
Well, let me ask you about.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yeah.
PETER BARRON: Where do you
stand now on Aung San Suu Kyi?
Because a lot of
people, Bob Geldof
is on handing back
their honors and so on.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: It's really--
PETER BARRON: Where do you
think we should stand on that?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
Deeply conflicted.
Having met her and
admired, I was then also
privileged to meet
her when she came
to Oslo to receive
her Nobel Peace Prize,
re-met her at that time.
And she came to
Amnesty International
to receive the Ambassador of
Conscience award that we gave.
So such an admirer.
She was so-- her courage
was so important.
And now we're seeing somebody
who is failing to speak out.
"Sad" is too soft a word.
I'm hesitating over
the word "criminal."
But it just-- it should
not be happening.
She is the woman who
understands integrity.
She is not showing
the integrity.
So the crimes against
humanity that we
are seeing in Myanmar against
the Rohingya minority there,
truly, truly terrible.
Amnesty International
recently published a report
which was going back two
years, been researching it
for two years, defining
it as apartheid the way
that Rohingya have
already been treated.
We do not use that word lightly.
I mean, that went through
many, many levels.
That's what we are seeing.
That was the kind of context.
And she has such a powerful,
important voice and yet
won't do it.
And you know, even if
the pope goes to Myanmar,
he has in effect told on no
account must you use this word.
The pope, who speaks
out on so many things,
but even using the
word "Rohingya,"
the Myanmar authorities say
we don't want it to happen.
So that's a very sad place.
And above all, it's
not good for Myanmar.
It's not good for the
minority, and indeed there
are other minorities who've
been persecuted there also.
But you know, that's
not good for the health
of the society in general.
And it's saddening
and it's appalling.
PETER BARRON: Yeah, yeah, OK.
Couple more pictures
and stories to tell.
And this is the sort of
role of art in all of this.
And Ai Weiwei, of course, writes
the foreword for the book.
He's one of the great
exponents of this.
So this is Porcelain Crab.
Tell us about that.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yes.
The River Crab.
So all of this
started-- it happens
in quite a lot of countries,
by actually the Chinese
are like masters at
this of the word play.
Word plays are used constantly
by Chinese for that sense of I
seem to be saying one
word, but actually I'm
kind of meaning a different one.
So Ai Weiwei, the artist,
I was so privileged
that he agreed to
write the foreword,
because he has exactly
that spirit of kind
of courageous mischief
in so much of his work.
And he was having difficulty
with the authorities
a few years ago, and they
were demolishing his studio.
And he organized a banquet
to kind of celebrate
the demolition.
So again, he kind
of turned the tables
on the authorities a little bit.
People gathered.
And what did they
serve at the banquet?
They served river crabs,
which is a Chinese delicacy.
But the important point
of the river crabs
is the word sounds almost
identical to the Chinese word
for harmonization.
And harmonization, in-turn, is
the official propaganda word,
which basically
means censorship.
You know, we will
all be harmonized.
You know, none of this edgy
stuff, we will be harmonized.
And so everyone knew
exactly what that meant,
and they loved eating
the river crabs.
And somebody who was
there said, are they
going to ban us eating
river crabs now, you know,
which is our tradition?
And so the art work by Ai
Weiwei, the porcelain river
crabs, I guess that
many people who
may have seen that exhibitions
in London and around the world
you know, if you might
walk past and just
think oh, that's
kind of interesting.
But actually it contains
in it that defiance
of censorship in this
very oblique kind of way.
But you know, instead of that
middle finger gesture, which
of course he's also
familiar with in different,
but this is a very oblique
way of saying the same thing.
I will not be muzzled.
And in fact, here are
thousands of river crabs.
Because no, I and we are
not going to stay silent.
PETER BARRON: Yeah.
That was extremely impressive.
And I think the next
picture is Ai Weiwei.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yeah.
PETER BARRON: That was when
he was in the lift, wasn't it?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: That's right.
And again, you
know, there he is.
He just doesn't stop.
So he'd been arrested.
He was speaking out
on behalf of people
who'd suffered very
badly and the authorities
had failed so
miserably in connection
with an earthquake
that had happened.
The authorities were so unhappy
they drag him out of his bed
and they beat him at that time.
And he actually after
this photo was taken
he had to be hospitalized.
And there was some quite
serious, and very serious
head injury.
But he, while he's
being arrested,
is in the elevator, hotel
elevator with the mirror,
takes a picture in the mirror
and then shares that globally.
So if you like, even though he's
in such a dangerous position,
he still continues to do that,
that familiar serious face
that we all know.
And it's like OK, you're
doing this to me and boom,
this is what I'm doing to you.
PETER BARRON: And I
love the quote, which
is "Never retreat, Retweet."
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
Isn't it glorious?
It's glorious, it's glorious.
Yes, it's very nice.
PETER BARRON: Good.
And I think our final
picture is again from China.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yeah.
PETER BARRON: And
this is doctoring
the archive, which
is sort of hilarious
but serious at the same time.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yeah, exactly.
I mean, again it's
the kind of mischief.
Of course, incredibly
serious the meaning of this.
So everybody will
recognize the photograph
that this is
originally taken from,
which is this unbelievable
courage of a man just
with some shopping
bags standing in front
of the tanks on Tiananmen Square
after the main massacre had
happened, but when killing was
still continuing at that time.
It's the picture of
the Tiananmen Square
Massacre of 1989 that
everyone knows and remembers.
And then on the anniversary
of that a couple of years ago,
the picture itself
is utterly banned.
It can't be shared.
And you know, and references
to it, all of those things.
So people tweaked the photo
and put the yellow ducks in,
which was in itself
a reference to some
of the stuff that was going on
with yellow ducks at that time.
PETER BARRON: That
means something else?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: No.
Actually it was to do
with an art exhibition.
There had been some
giant ones in Hong Kong.
And so took these.
And this went completely viral.
And then the hashtag of "plastic
yellow ducks" also went viral.
And so as one person
said, you know,
it's the kind of
the digital one,
the authorities nil,
basically, you know.
It was the victory in such
difficult circumstances.
Because this is a theme which is
first, forbidden to talk about.
So it requires real
courage to talk about it.
And second, the
authorities say well,
why would anyone want
to talk about it?
It's so long again and
it's utterly uninteresting.
No one's interested.
And this defied both of those.
It kind of said yes,
we're talking about it.
And the way it went viral
reminded people that yeah,
it may have been a long time
ago, coming up 30 years ago,
but unless you go to the
heart of the truth telling,
you don't get the stability
that your country really needs.
I think that's the kind of
powerfulness that comes out.
PETER BARRON: And the
person who created that
would be in big
trouble if identified.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Absolutely.
Yeah, no, that
would be for sure.
So as so often, you know, you
appear to be doing mischief,
but mischief is not the easy.
Mischief is a very,
very courageous version.
PETER BARRON: Great.
Well, we're going to come
to questions in a second.
How long have we got left?
I haven't got my watch on me.
But how long?
AUDIENCE: Twenty minutes.
PETER BARRON: Twenty
minutes, excellent.
So we'll come to
questions in a second.
So for final thought is, you
and I grew up going on demos,
you know, sort of the
marching down the street.
Is the kind of old
fashioned traditional demo,
is that not enough anymore?
Is that over?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Obviously,
it remains really important.
I mean, the funny thing is when
I was writing this book in 2016
and I was thinking, oh,
does anyone except me really
care about protests?
At that point it felt as
though it was a slightly
esoteric thing I
cared about a lot
and I thought of lots
of nice stories to tell.
And then you know, this
guy with the weird head
gets elected president
in the United States,
you know, overturning
all expectations.
And as we all know, protests
became very, very big.
And of course, with
mischief as well.
I mean, the women's
protests that
kicked off the inauguration
of Donald Trump
back in January 2017,
but many other protests,
including in the United
Kingdom as well we've
seen vast protests
on a range of things,
partly against Trump, the Brexit
issue, but many other things.
So I think those things
are definitely there.
What's interesting,
and I think that sense
that we can make a difference
I would like to think people
believe.
Although I read an
interestingly large number
of pieces that say you know,
the age of protest is dead.
PETER BARRON: And
so sometimes it
has an extraordinary
effect and then sometimes--
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Exactly.
PETER BARRON: --you see a huge
build up and nothing happens.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
And that's the point
is that often you can't tell.
And what's really interesting
is often the things-- you know,
you could have said in
Burma a few years ago,
we didn't need to,
and people did.
They say said, oh, they're
very brave and all that,
but none of that's going
to change anything,
and it ended up
changing big things.
We're in a democracy,
there's a kind of paradox.
It's, of course, much
easier to protest.
You're taking fewer risks.
But in a sense, the people
you are protesting against
are more comfortable.
So there's a Polish poem
I'm very fond of called
"Those Men So Powerful."
And whose punchline at the end--
it's all about the people who
have all the power over you.
"In the end, in the end, it is
they who are afraid the most."
That poem was
written before even
Solidarity that I was
describing existed.
That was written
back in the 1970s.
It was a declaration
of hope, not certainty.
But he was proved exactly right
that the unelected leaders
fundamentally live in fear,
because they know they
kind of shouldn't be there.
Elected leaders, even if they're
doing really bad things--
and that's not just the
United States, that's
in Turkey, that's in
Philippines, that's in Poland,
there's a whole
bunch of places--
they feel much more comfortable.
So in those circumstances, it's
much harder to make the impact
because as we've seen from the
tweeter-in-chief in Washington
it just knocks back.
But actually, I think it's
important to think because you
don't see an impact today,
tomorrow, the next day, that
doesn't mean that it
hasn't had any impact.
At a certain point, there are
others who go, enough already.
And at a certain point,
a leader, I think,
governments are
forced to make change.
So we definitely, definitely
shouldn't sit at home
while a demo is happening.
PETER BARRON: Yeah, exactly.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
When things anger us,
we need to get out there.
PETER BARRON: So the
message of the book
really is even small
acts of subversion
are well worth while.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
Exactly, exactly.
And don't believe
that the book is
littered with quotes from
people who said oh, grow up.
It's very sweet that you think
this can make a difference.
It totally won't
make a difference.
And in one case, the
Soviet coup in August 1991,
there was a columnist
who I quote,
"I don't know why
they're even bothering.
This obviously is never
going to succeed."
He wrote that.
It appeared in print
on a Wednesday morning.
By Wednesday afternoon,
because of the courage
of tens of thousands in Moscow
and hundreds of thousands
around the country,
the coup had collapsed.
He never, of course,
admitted that.
But you know, that
sense of don't
listen to people who
say nothing will happen.
It might not happen immediately,
but things do create change.
PETER BARRON: Brilliant.
Great.
Questions for Steve?
AUDIENCE: Can you perhaps
talk about the sort of work
that you're doing
around kind of refugees
and basically, you
know, getting society
to kind of feel more charitable,
giving to people in need?
And you know, I guess in human
nature and natural politics
it's very easy to
go oh, you know,
English jobs so English
people or all that kind
of very nativism.
How do you see us fighting that?
You know, what is the
message of inclusion
that we should put out?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yeah, yeah.
Thank you so much.
I always love Q&A so
much because they always
ask you the questions that
you actually wanted to answer
but never quite fit in.
Refugees is something
I've been working on,
especially recently.
But my organization, Amnesty
International, of course,
like many others, is
working very much on that.
And you rightly
describe certainly
in Europe, but actually
around the world,
these kind of toxic narratives
that we want our country back.
We don't want them.
That, of course, echoes things
that we've seen over the years
as well.
I mean again, just to take this
country and this continent,
looking at the 1930s, the
parallels of people trying
to flee Nazism and the
push back are kind of
staggering and depressing.
And you know, describing Syrians
as the problem when they're
actually fleeing
these horrific things,
it's so offensive
on every level.
But one of the things
is you can't just
preach at people because
people are feeling insecure.
And if you've got people who
are feeding them narratives
about why this is
dangerous and you know bad
and if there's a danger
of being-- and of course,
the danger of terrorism
we all see is there.
You know, people
are being blown up.
So you've got a climate
of fear potentially,
which can be stoked.
So I don't think there is
any easy, quick solution,
but you addressed
something that all of us
are thinking about a lot,
which is how people just
get the empathy of being able
to think into the other person's
shoes.
One video that I love, which
colleagues from Amnesty
International Poland did.
It's an incredibly
simple one, which
is just two minutes of
silence of two people looking
at each other, one
person from here
and one person who has
arrived from there.
And there's a series of I
can't remember 10, 20 people.
And you see them.
First, I've never met you
before and I'm looking.
And then looking into
the person's eyes.
The connections that are
made during that brief time,
and then the embrace that
often finishes that, including
tears coming to people's eyes.
For me, it's really interesting.
Because as I look and I
think what your story might
be and then reflect in
many countries in Europe,
certainly including,
for example, Poland,
what my own country
has gone through,
and you begin to feel that.
And I think that none of
that is an easy answer
of what we must do.
Because these toxic
narratives that we're hearing,
they're incredibly easy to play.
And so there are just ways
that we can turn around,
not by saying you
mustn't, you mustn't, you
mustn't, which kind
of can sometimes work,
but people put up
their barriers.
And it's right to say
this is against the law
and this is your obligation,
all of which is absolutely true.
The UN Refugee Convention is
so clear in what the European
Union has failed to do.
It puts up more barriers
instead of allowing in.
All of that is
true, but we kind of
need people to
feel that empathy.
And people are not bad,
as such, of course.
You know, we know that
from our own neighbors
and friends and colleagues.
But creating that empathy
I think is so important.
PETER BARRON: Next question.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
That was really,
really interesting.
I just wanted to sort
of ask your perspective
from Amnesty
International's perspective
on the events that have
taken place in Zimbabwe.
And it always
occurred to me that--
and this is probably naivete of
what kind of protest movement
was going on there--
and was there a
protest movement that
sort of led the
dethroning of Mugabe
and ushering in
potentially this new era.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
Yeah, Zimbabwe is
a very good example of
nothing will change,
nothing will change.
And the way that the
changes have happened
is a kind of
complex one as well.
And to be blunt, I am expecting
without particular knowledge,
but that Amnesty
International will probably
be publishing reports about
difficult things still going
on.
You know, we haven't reached
the green sunny uplands
I don't think yet.
But just to welcome
in the short sense
that one set of really
bad things has finished.
So to answer your
question, yeah.
I mean, civil society has
been really strong there.
The danger of raising
your voice has been huge.
People have suffered
very greatly.
And I massively admire
the Zimbabweans,
of whom there have
been many, who
have dared to put their
heads above the parapet.
And indeed, I have
written before now there
have been some, again, some
quite nice mischievous things
with theater productions.
I mean, there are
all sorts of things
that they have done in different
ways and different connections.
One of the things, I was
actually really honored
with this book with
"Street Spirit"
is a group before the fall
of Robert Mugabe, who'd
been there forever and ever.
But they got in touch
saying could they
do a graphic novel version.
They were already using the
stories of "Street Spirit"
because they found them fun to
play with thinking oh, maybe we
could use some of those ideas.
And they-- I don't know if
it's going to happen yet,
but there was discussion of
doing a graphic novel version,
which I would be so happy for.
In other words, the
stories seek to be
accessible in any
case with pictures.
But graphic novel, obviously,
is an incredibly powerful way.
And the thought
of the people who
in Zimbabwe who were thinking
about that was the more that we
can create a sense of belief
that we can achieve something,
I think that's
incredibly important.
And in a way, it is the
theme of everything else
I've been discussing.
The Russian opposition
leader Alexei Navalny
came out with an interesting
line at an election rally
or at a political rally some
time ago or earlier this year
where he said the
greatest problem
we face-- he asked the crowd.
And they talked about
corruption and this and that.
And he said no, no, the
greatest problem we fear,
face, is lack of belief in the
possibility of creating change.
And it's true.
It's really hard.
And I think many Zimbabweans
probably did feel that.
And that was why we saw
such incredible ecstasy
when the change came.
But the people who continue
to fight for that change
definitely have contributed.
I think there's no
question on that, yeah.
PETER BARRON: Another question?
Any?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Can you talk a little bit
more about slacktivism
and clicktivism and
the kind of tension
between how easy it
is in the online world
to like something
and click and you
feel like you've done your bit?
You don't need to put on your
boots and go out and walk.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, another
important question.
And it gives me the excuse,
talking of newly coined words,
to mention laughtivism, which
is a different category,
but which I love.
Which is coined by a Serb
activist, Srdja Popovic,
who wrote a book called
"Blueprint for Revolution."
And he talks about
laughtivism, which in a sense,
is the theme we've been
talking about today of mischief
and activism put together.
But your reference to
clicktivism and slacktivism
and the idea that you're not
really going out on the street,
you're just oh
yeah, I support you.
And now I support you.
And now I support you,
and it doesn't really
involve any commitment.
Massively mocked.
And it's true that, of course,
just doing that and not
being engaged, if you
just kind of don't even
think about it again,
oh, I've clicked
so I've been a good person,
that doesn't help much.
But I think we are wrong to
think that the online stuff is
somehow irrelevant.
It plays-- I mean, Black
Lives Matter, for example,
is one example of things
just gaining an enormous
and the people who said yeah,
like Black Lives Matter.
You say, well yeah,
OK, you've clicked.
But then that went
together those people who
felt engaged actually
did go out on the street.
And actually in the prologue
to Black Lives Matter happening
when there was the
protest against Trayvon
Martin and the person who shot
him dead not being punished,
that was, again,
an online petition
which went so viral with so
many, many, many millions
that that kind of went from
being a story that wasn't even
on page 17 let alone on the
front page to being something
that the President of the
United States was talking about.
So that was without much
protest in the street.
So yes, clicking isn't
going to solve the problems
of the world, to put it mildly.
But we are gravely
mistaken if we just think
it's completely irrelevant.
Another example, which
is not clicking directly,
but that sense of online-ness.
In Egypt in 2011
when Mubarak fell,
there was one
Facebook post there
which went so completely viral
saying, unless you go out,
then you are part
of the problem.
If you say, I'm not going
out because not enough people
will go out, like
you've just made
it certain that it will fail.
And that post went so viral
that millions, as we know,
did go out and Mubarak fell.
That all happened only a couple
of months after a mocking,
mocking piece had
appeared in one
of the world's most
respected magazines
explaining to us why all
this online stuff was
utterly, utterly irrelevant.
And that was when that change
had already begun in Egypt.
So yes, I think we
should definitely beware
of clicktivism in isolation.
But ways of making
people think about how
they relate to the
rest of the world,
I think that's important
still definitely.
AUDIENCE: We have
time for one more.
PETER BARRON: One more question.
AUDIENCE: I have one more.
PETER BARRON: Oh,
one more, go on.
AUDIENCE: Steve, which human
rights issues in the world
today are not gaining the
attention of the world's
media or most people?
What do we not have our eye on?
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Wow,
that's such a good question.
I ought to have
prepared for it better.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: I'm kind
of thinking here, OK.
Yemen and what's
happening in Yemen,
I'm glad-- that which is vast
numbers of civilians dying.
Saudi bombing,
Western governments
supporting, selling the
arms and making that happen.
People are partly aware of
that, but too little aware,
I would say.
Let me stick with that.
I mean, there are other things.
Syria, that the danger is that
people kind of move on from it
somehow.
You know, oh, I've been
reading about that for so long.
The suffering is still enormous
and the suffering in Syria
continues.
Rohingya, Myanmar people
are talking about it.
But again, the
danger is it's like
OK, let's move on from that.
But I guess if you were
to ask me one thing,
it astonishes me that
it's not something
that everybody's
thinking about it's
probably what's
happening in Yemen.
PETER BARRON: Steve
Crawshaw, thank you so much.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW: Thank you.
PETER BARRON: Inspiring and
important and very entertaining
stuff, so thank you.
STEVEN CRAWSHAW:
Thank you very much.
And thank you to everyone here.
Thank you very much, indeed.
[APPLAUSE]